[Applaudissements]
Je suis venu de la campagne O j'ai
laissez-faire mois deux sabots
Oh je suis venu de la campagne oou j'ai
laissez-vous avoir
Marga Je suis parti battre la campagne
verser et montrer les heures du mois
Oh je suis parti battre la campagne pour
et chercher d'autre
Margot
en chemin fit la connaissance de trois
boyou du meilleur
lot ils étaient trois nous fumes qu Je
Je battis mange un
Heroes Tous ces honneurs vite pesent Sur
mes épaules et le cur beau
Oh je ne singea qu'des faer pour
accourir jusqu'à
Margot la fortune comme la misère Ne
vous lche pas de si
Oh princesse jul de pl l'sur moi
Au conduire
chte on écrit une légende répandue à
Tous
Après la savoie jusqu'au flandres
mon nom tape comme un
donnez à DS la campagne de prix la chance
sourit
ausit On Me fit compte de bretagne mre
de
[Musique]
br Tous ces honneurs vite
Sur mes épaules et le cur gr
Oh Je Ne singea qu'des faer pour courir
jusqu'à
Margot parpen ma Belle princesse rendez-vous
les Moi m de
sabot mon pauvre cur est en détresse
après avoir perdu
Margot par pitié ma Belle princesse
rendez-vous les Moi mais de
sabon Je Ne suis rien Je le confesse Je
je suis né la dans le
hameau ma Belle princesse rendez Moi
mais de sabau
Oh je ne suis rien je le confesse je
je suis dans le
[Musique]
SUIS